le handicap est il enfin banalisée à la
tv c'est parti aujourd'hui maintenant on
est dans les séries télé dans les
émissions de télé on en parle de plus en
plus donc ça se banalise et on va se
demander s'il n'ya pas encore qui était
fort à faire pour que ce soit également
dans sur les plateaux de télé et à la
place des animateurs est avec nous j'ai
le plaisir d'écrire une jeune femme
qu'on a découvert en soirée la
télévision lors d'une émission qui
s'appelle le grand oral c'est virginie
de la langue là la révélation pour moi
de ce programme vous êtes vous êtes
avocate
on regarde le portrait et on parle juste
après un génie n'était pas du tout prêt
destiné à faire des études d'avocat à
neuf mois les médecins ont diagnostiqué
une surdité profonde lordinot sic était
que virginie non seulement n'entendrez
pas mais ne parlerait jamais comme un
fait pour mener sabir quand on est
différent quand on a de l'ambition mais
certains modèles 4 à 7 bat schéma
émotion pour tous ceux qui ont vu ce
programme pourrait qu'on est très fier
et très heureux de vous avoir sur ce
plateau et moi la question qui me à tous
et comment fait-on pour devenir avocate
qui est quand même un métier on doit
faire appel évidemment à la parole à
l'éloquence
il faut convaincre un jury etc c'est un
vrai travail comment est-ce qu'on
devient avocate quand on est quand on
est sourd de naissance à leur hôtel
après tout les rames ou sur wii n'est
surtout pas aidé par le professeur
université pour que c'est vraiment la
méthode de la débrouille et heureusement
il y avait des amis
notes le fait au départ un petit peu
pitié de moi et puis après tout peut
devenir de braid ami/ennemi avons fait
nos études
or la production le handicap est présent
dans les séries télé les présents on l'a
vu dans les émissions de télévision
compris des reportages on vous a fait un
petit récap on en parle juste après
c'est parti
c'est une véritable révolution qui
s'opère sous nos yeux à la télé depuis
quelques temps avant les personnes
malades est en situation de handicap
visible et invisible à la télévision on
en parlait au téléthon une fois par an
et c'est d'être aujourd'hui ces
personnes sont de plus en plus mise en
avant et bien sûr c'est tant mieux
aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour cette
semaine la série des brassées rouge qui
raconte l'histoire d'adolescents
atteints de maladies a cartonné au point
que tf1 a déjà commandé une saison 3 il
faut dire que cette fiction passionne
les français on était encore plus de 5
millions derrière nos écrans pour le
dernier épisode de la saison 2 lundi
soir
record d'audience également pour ça
commence aujourd'hui sur france 2 cette
semaine grâce à son numéro spécial sur
les autiste asperger
[Musique]
bonjour à tous alors aujourd'hui c'est
la journée mondiale de sensibilisation à
l'autisme l'autisme c'est aussi le thème
central de la nouvelle série médicale à
succès de tf1 good doctor qui a cartonné
pour sa première saison
l'acteur freddie highmore joue à
merveille le rôle d'un médecin génie
mais autistes en remercie beaucoup en
2019 le handicap ne se cache plus dans
les séries comme plus belle la vie qui
intègre le handicap
anne décis joue le rôle d'une
tétraplégie bois ainsi que julien
baumgartner dans carne
une manière de s'en créer encore plus
dans la réalité est d'être un vrai
reflet de la société
évidemment parmi les précurseurs en la
matière cyril hanouna et benjamin
castaldi qui depuis des années propose
des émissions où il met en lumière des
personnes en situation de handicap et
pmp va être ouvert à tout le monde
le vendredi alors pensez vous que le
handicap est entré dans les moeurs et
enfin banalisée à la télé cette édition
est évidemment dû délaisser ses très
heureux et très fier qu'il ait confié
les rênes du vendredi pour cette raison
oui qu'est ce qui est à rachel alors moi
j'ai un vrai coup de gueule parce que je
crois que c'est la france qui est
handicapé dans ce domaine là il ya une
vraie carence sur le sujet et j'aimerais
dire une chose les jeunes qui nous
regardent et qui ont adoré comme nous
tous par exemple les bracelets rouge
ils ont droit eux aussi d'avoir des
idoles qui puisse accrocher des posters
dans leur chambre et qu'ils puissent
s'identifier
parce que quand il regarde par exemple
des artistes et des acteurs des
chanteurs qui ne leur ressemblent pas ça
les renvoie à leurs propres
malheureusement handicap ils ont besoin
aussi d'avoir des ailes qui leur
ressemble quand même
avouez quand même que depuis quelques
années et un effort qui est fait non
merci alors la main sur mouloud en arial
avait rien frédéric je crois que je
crois qu'on pose mal le problème je suis
pas là pour donner des leçons aucunement
mais je crois que le problème il est à
la base le problème n'est pas de savoir
s'il ya de plus en plus de personnes
handicapées allant à la télévision c'est
bien qu'on soit de plus en plus visible
c'est parfait je pense que le problème
il est dans la cité dans la cité au sens
latin du terme dans la ville tant que le
regard ne sera pas banaliser le handicap
ne sera pas banal aujourd'hui prendre le
métro prend des transports il ya collé
line 14 dans le métro qui
aujourd'hui le problème il est là si si
demain comme à new york où comme à
montréal
être en fauteuil roulant devient
totalement banale et ne fait ni pleurer
ni rire personne
le combat sera gagné j'avais senti le
regard des gens sur vous et cette gêne
qui pouvait avoir en vous en vous
écoutant alors oui le regard alors il
n'a pas brûlé il est le même c'est à
dire que il ya une personnalité du père
que déjà m'apprécient vous me devez
arrêter terrain mais un aveu je suis
très impressionné cecobois l'euro ce que
doit être le porte parole de tout un
nombre de personnes qui au fait si de
type i am a surpris notamment je vous ai
centaines de milliers de messages
d'erreur toumodi
enfin voila voila je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord avec ce que disait rachel
souvenons nous disant marion y avait
peut-être une sensibilisation mais pas
de politique pas d'action rien y avait
là des gens qui sont les handicaps
téléthon et 10 ans mais en paraît fois
par an y'avait rien mais gilles la loi
la loi sur le handicap elle n'est pas
respectée
aujourd hui mais elle est là explique
pas oui mais richesse à la télé les
chaînes ont été proactive présentation
des handicapés dans les médias que
c'était 0,6 pour cent alors qu'à 12% de
la population qui est handicapé donc à
un moment donné il fallait que les
choses changent je pense que c'est un
chiffre de 2010 est qu'il n'ya pas eu de
nouvelle comptabilité le moment ce sera
non mais ça va pas être énormément plus
là moi je trouverais que les choses ont
changé quand les acteurs des séries
seront vraiment handicapé là là on
prendra des handicapés pour jouer leur
propre rôle
parce que les jeunes qui sont super
juste parce qu'ils sont très bons c'est
acteurs mais ça reste des acteurs nagera
des vrais handicapés pour jouer les
rôles
je pense que le combat sera gagné
lorsque ce ne sera plus valeureux de
mettre des handicapés à d'image on se
sera à nice
et si tu veux parler de la loi par les
danois de conformité elle le repousse et
sans arrêt sans arrêt sans arrêt sans
arrêt